two welcome everybody
to the h3 podcast
i am your host evan klein the pr fresh
prince of dead air
with me is my beautiful co-host and wife
thank you hila cline of course some
people say we are
the um what they say in that tim and
eric sketch the
married news casters jan and skylar
that's us of the podcasting world
is it corny that we're married and
hosting a podcast together
uh probably yeah but it's known too
right i mean you just got to embrace
what we are today's episode good luck
ethan oh
he's so keemstar is so nice he's safe
yeah today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn meundies and upstart
i'm a little bit out of it and i'll tell
you why
because i took nyquil like three days
ago
does any does that happen to anyone else
like i had a headache
and i just wanted to go to bed so i like
chugged a little bit of nyquil
and yesterday i was totally trashed i
was like
useless all day and today i'm still like
a little bit out of it
from one i don't get it but yeah i i had
the same thing and i don't touch that
stuff nick was like the hardest drug
you can take like oh my god
does anyone else have uh like am i
overreacting to
nyquil i mean i don't know what's going
on well nyquil
unless they've changed it has alcohol in
it right it does
yeah i don't think it's the alcohol bro
well aren't you on uh
some some um pharmaceuticals that you
yeah well i
i think it yes i think it might be
interacting with my alexa pro but
it's not the alcohol i mean i've drank
it's not like that
there's some [ __ ] in there this
man i had this hor i mean i hate when
people talk about the dreams but i'll
just tell you real
like for example when i woke up this
morning i had a dream that we were all
in afghanistan
me you my parents and the dogs and we
all got murdered
including the dogs what yeah and that's
what i woke up to
buy some tears i haven't had dreams like
that since i was literally
executed with my whole family this
morning how was your day
[Laughter]
i used to have dreams like that in high
school and and
elementary school too really elementary
school yeah
sheesh it's too early for that guy i
know
so yeah that's how i woke up this
morning horrid growing up
i remember thinking like even the
[ __ ] dogs
that was the dog so you were still
thinking after you died
yeah cool
yeah because you don't really die right
you're dreaming
anyway anyway
you know listen there's there's so much
to talk about today
yeah more than just dreams yeah i just
want to
give everyone an expectation that this
is going to be one of those episodes
it's funny that you say that because
i've been feeling like [ __ ] too
but i have no explanation why unlike you
i didn't take anything
you've been feeling like [ __ ] like what
um i don't know i just didn't even
want to think about being on camera and
having you think you look bad
you think you're having a bad hair day
well it's more than that
i feel bad therefore i look bad oh
you think it's like that you feel bad
and that fulfills the
yeah does it manifest physically
interesting
i would think it would be the opposite
maybe
you think you look bad therefore you
feel bad
or you think you look bad i feel bad
that's interesting i didn't know it
worked that way
i think you look great thank you 10 out
of 10 every day
i hit that and i do
tear that that's really look how
beautiful she is all right ben she's
taken
chill finn is eating having a good hair
day
am i right or wrong i don't know
i made a statement
um so anyway today we have ben shapiro
calling in to talk about the new
cardi b video which is pretty
interesting because you know he had a
very
viral reaction to it last time
so i'm very much looking forward to hear
what he has to say about it
yeah you know i'm sure he's gonna have a
lot to say about it
um but until then
i wanted to give a shout out to our boy
tim dillon who is deep
undercover on the impulsive podcast who
you know is enemy
is our basically enemy of the podcast
you have friends of the podcast these
are
our enemies of the podcast over in wood
i think there's a lot of people like
like
makes me laugh ethan makes me laugh a
lot like those people oh
like i think there's i appreciate every
cricket
bro crickets on impulsive
you know why is there no angle of logan
yeah they cut they definitely cut away
from his face because we looked
abe was in there kind of looking for
reactions when he mentions me and they
they didn't give us anything
so yeah i think they cut it out hmm
what do you think i'm a strawberry
i wonder what kind of face he did like
he just tried to play cool like don't
yeah don't let him know that he i think
he's come to the internet
he can't even admit that like well
whatever tim dillon
shout out to tim yeah shout out to tim's
family doing undercover work man
rocking the boat you know how we feel
about that now
okay one other thing before we get into
this
main conversation we'll be getting into
ab
is the main simp it turns out ab is not
just a sim for me he's a sim for other
people
all right including among others david
dobrik
no um is that chi um for more than i
don't know is that
what do you think baby is it illegal to
just simp
i haven't checked the guidebook but he's
like a mormon simp
i think to be a samp you have to have
one
in my opinion to be a true simpson so
maybe
what someone who has a bunch of sims or
who's like lex
um i think that's just a mormon simp
you believe in polygamy
yeah i think i think you use the word
simp and stand a little bit
liberally so okay
you are you a simp of mine or a stan of
mine
i'll take simp of yours okay but are you
a simp
a stan of david dobrik's i like david's
videos but i haven't like kept up with
them in a long
time i haven't watched them yeah okay
that's good
i just want to make sure i'm higher on
the stratosphere and michael jackson
where would you
put your symptom for him because i know
you love to defend michael jackson
that's a conversation for another day
but
i'm curious where you stand uh that's
another thing
i feel like you kind of i don't know i
don't like talking about the michael
thing but
really yeah oh okay we don't have to
talk about michael
just curious i just feel like i i would
need to properly
explain myself because i know a lot of
people get offended and i
and i believe that they have a right to
it's just a touchy subject
well hey a lot of people disagree with
me i mean that was a big controversy
when i made that episode
probably one of our most disliked
episodes ever so you're not in the
minority by any means or well you might
be but
you're not you know alone not alone so
how would you i'm just curious how would
you write michael jackson
in the stratosphere of great men that
you aspire
or that you you uh you admire
i just want to be like you man that's it
okay thank you good call
well stated okay so a b
being a fan of david dobrik you you've
we've been arguing a little bit
behind the scenes about some of the
things going on so i thought let's talk
about it on the podcast it's only fair
that david has somebody you know on the
crew
that supports him gives a little counter
argument so abe
what are your thoughts on david dobrik
hit me with it
well yeah i'm not like yeah like i said
i'm not like a huge fan but i i've
watched him in the past
um but i just feel like we're going a
little bit harsh
and from the outside looking in i know
it could look a little bit
insane but i feel like anyone who keeps
up with david or is familiar with his
content knows that
everyone kind of talks to each other in
a certain way
it's kind of maybe you know trisha is
going to murder you right
oh 100 before you continue i just want
to know what you're getting yourself
into
she's going to bury she's going to body
slam you and bury you maybe
because he's an idiot
but go ahead no i think i'm i'm
interested to hear you outside
i'm not and i'm not protect you as best
as i can
thank you i'm i'm not saying trisha is
lying i'm not saying
her feelings aren't valid her feelings
are valid everything she's saying i'm
not taking away from that
i'm just saying there's another
perspective you know we're going a
little hard on jason
calling him you know saying he's
pathetic and
i just felt like there's there's more to
it like he's he's self-aware that
for example jason for donald jason that
he's a failed actor and that david
basically
saved his career he has two kids that he
has to take care of it's not like it's
not
yeah but like i think her criticism is
that he was like creeping on an 18 year
old
when they were together right but if you
watch the videos it's like
it fits the narrative of a lot of this
you think it was a gag
you think it wasn't as real she thought
it was real
i guess i guess i don't know i mean i i
hear you but i guess as her girlfriend
at this
same time you're like uh yeah but
they're
trying to get them to [ __ ] you know i
really don't want to like
bring trish into this god no let's go
there but like there were bits where
like she was talking about my house oh
my god
one of the younger guys she always said
she did
patricia what's going on and
you know there's always jokes about how
like you know she's obsessed with david
and how she would hook up with david
that was a
common joke amongst them but
uh oh it's like it's like
it's like a sitcom sort of in a way that
stuff is exaggerated there everything
there's bits and then
people break character and they leave
those in the vlogs it's like people have
very exaggerated characters and
so your your point is that it's all kind
of just fantasy
played up for the camera yeah just stick
right well i'm sure trish will have
plenty to say about that
i think you're partially right you know
if my hunch is you're partially right
but and again like i said i'm not
and what's interesting to me is behind
the scenes people begging david not to
put [ __ ] in
and then but he then he does and like
jason being like don't put in this tan
of [ __ ]
and he does you know that seems weird
that's not really sitcom ish is it
that's like
weird reality tv right but
it's again i mean
it seems very light-hearted for a lot of
stuff they put in
like i mean of course he should he
should respect that but
i mean and what about big nick saying
that he felt like he was bullied and
that he had no self-worth
and that um he had to really get out of
the situation because he thought it was
toxic
i mean i i feel bad for big nick i mean
i know there's a lot of jokes that were
made but
he went back and forth as well i mean
everyone makes fun of
everyone else in the group but i don't
think
like nick was even commenting on david's
instagram post
not even like it was like two and a half
months ago
um i believe that
this post here yeah
someone said david looks like kalu's dad
and then big nick said heard you're
looking for me what the joke is that
he's
kalu is that my saying that right kalu
are you
caillou
um i guess david's perfume commented
dude come on chill out
david has like this perfume and he's
it's commenting on all of his posts like
come on
[Laughter]
david's perfume laughing emoji why is
perfume laughing emotion your perfume
you don't emote
it should just be a bottle of perfume
every time
that's hilarious i sympathize i feel for
nick i really do
but like teddy fresh commenting on all
your posts with trying to laughing
emojis
sorry that's a little corny if it was
just perfume bottles i'd be fine with it
oh wow he redid the photo that's pretty
epic i'm gonna hate on that
that's really good
like everyone on in the vlog kind of
built off their viner personality
and a big nick you know he made some
videos about dwarves he collabs with
other creators lance stewart
did bits about dwarfs and i i'm not
saying that it's okay what david did if
he felt that way but david probably
assumed it was okay because they all rip
on each other
and um even nick's mom was in the videos
like playing along like she
she would play along with the bits like
there i have right here there's a little
um little compilation just two
short videos where maybe he's going in
dude okay i'm here for it big nick's mom
apparently
on in on this gag nick introduce us to
your mom
this is my mom hi do you have any things
to say about nick that you've never told
anyone before
your vlogs are so amazing i'm an old
woman and i just watched them do you get
angry when i make fun of nick in the
vlogs
no because i don't no no no you're nicer
to him than i am oh
my mom calls me dumb [ __ ] every day
really really guessing
[ __ ] this vlog is actually sponsored by
picnic productions oh shut up yeah you
did a best friend's for life
we did it was cute by the way he said
that he
feels bad because he didn't talk to
anyone about how bad he was feeling
including his mom so
i'm not sure that this really means
anything she's just being a supportive
mom
right now are you writing a book about
big names
really yeah this is a coloring book by
the way she never made fun of his height
that she's just going along yeah she's
just being a nice good sport
that's what i'm saying is that they just
went along with it like an example
when we were supporting her son come on
she's just supporting her son a.b
come on man i don't think you've ever
been in a situation
of like abuse have you ever been abused
baby
it's just before you joined the show
mentally
yeah either one have you
um no no okay
so that's the mass weapons by now i can
tell
from personal experience that
um when you're in an abusive situation
you can go along with it at the time
because you don't know better you think
you want it
um so it's not that black and white and
where you're those arguments right now
are just kind of
it's like the typical [ __ ] that people
say it's like oh you went along with it
he wanted it it's like
a victim i'm not going to call you a
victim
but it's like how they rationalize it's
rationalizing
basically a toxic situation that
shouldn't have happened
i don't know that this is that bad you
know i don't want to make it more
serious than it is but i just see
you know something that to me it's
obvious
that something that was toxic and nick
is still trying to
come to terms with it and he himself is
still not even fully over it
right i i agree i'm but what i'm saying
is i could see
how david possibly overlooked it when
he's dealing with 20 other people every
day yeah fine you can overlook it for
a certain amount of time but when you
are becoming successful
you get a lot of responsibilities too
and one of them
is starting to become more professional
and considerate you have to become more
considerate you have to understand that
this is a business
and while you're making tons of money
you also need to be responsible towards
the people who are helping you make that
money
and you can't be like in the
mentality of a kid just like hey i'm
just having fun and this is all of a
sudden successful it's like
okay maybe for the first few months but
once you're making millions
and this is a huge business and you're
getting really famous
you also have a lot of responsibility
yeah and the amount of eyeballs on nick
he said like he would go in public and
people would make fun of himself yeah
you know i'd like to thank
signed up to being made fun of in public
every time he gets
recognized he consented but like he's in
this situation where
you don't necessarily know what you're
getting where you're going yeah i agree
with elo's
perspective on this and i'm not saying
david's a bad guy but he
definitely has this tunnel vision and
he's just so set
on success and fame in doing that i
don't think he thinks about collateral
damage
he's like a bull in a china shop or
something like they say and he's just
charging forward and
not really looking out at the collateral
damage i don't think he's a bad guy
he's just super motivated and not very
compassionate
thoughts i agree with everything you
guys are saying yeah i'm just saying
like
i from his point of view especially at
his age but you're right with power
comes responsibility you know as he gets
bigger but
you know just so much going on with them
all having their own vlogs as well you
know they they all have their own vlogs
that
featured david in them and vice versa
and they're all making similar jokes
i'm just saying i could see i could see
how he overlooked it and and nick said
as soon as he did tell david david he
cut him out
he said he apologized but yeah he
apologized and then he never had him in
another video yeah
i mean david is not stupid you know he's
a smart guy
you apologize to make it go away well i
think that's more about
him nick becoming like a again christian
because he like
you think that happened right at the
same time i don't know
yeah because he said like he the stuff
he used to take part in witchcraft he
used to say that's
uh who what say what what about spirit
cooking
this is stuff he used to take part in in
the vlogs and stuff he's just saying oh
he renounced it as witchcraft
yeah witchcraft is dope
i want to get into some witchcraft i'm
confused wait did
actual witchcraft or he was just using
that as like a metaphor for
uh the negativity of what they were
doing
kind of witchcraft they doing yeah what
kind of like are they summoning well he
i believe he was referring to the
negativity but he was saying like he
took part in and
partying and and well he used the words
witchcraft i mean i don't know if
there's some other
meaning that i don't know that ball [ __ ]
going on in the two demons
we got a tuba demons over here we got it
i'm healed in the name of well anyway i
understand
look i don't i don't think there's more
much more to say about it but
the uh look it's a gaze into the
i think david needs to be more
compassionate he needs to be more
thoughtful with how he
use people because he's he's very
clearly using people
and even if they consent to it
he's in this position of such power
and so much influence that if he misuse
people
then he can really [ __ ] them up and like
when nick's going out in public he's
getting abused and stuff
they deserve more consideration that
especially someone like big nick who's
like
also the dude has a disability it's not
like oh he's he's dopey it's like the
guy has a [ __ ] disability i don't
know
i'm sure that that doesn't feel good to
be always like
i don't know i know no i think have you
ever been body slammed by 220 pounds of
pure [ __ ]
uh force i'm describing trisha body
slamming
wwe style she told me
she said she's 220 and you said 240. no
i said 220.
have you ever been body slammed by 220
pounds of [ __ ]
force of god no no you're about to get
me you have to feel it
i do want to say just real quick if i
can that i was
a part of a group in college like i grew
up
i'm i didn't grow up on other arabs i
mixed in college
there were other you know i felt like i
finally was part of something i belonged
in i was in this organization
i'll give you guys a fast version and i
uh basically left the group because
there are some problems
and i know what it's like to be part of
something and then
to leave it and then see them still
together i know that's one of the most
hurtful things in the world so i do
sympathize patricia i really do feel bad
for her i know it's
it sucks but um i'm not trying to make
light of her situation whatsoever i'm
just trying to say that
i don't think the fact that i don't
think her hurt has to do with the fact
that
she's not part of the group well
i mean no i mean they're i'm it's part
you're burying yourself bro i'm just
going down
in flames you don't think it bothers her
is it a b because he's an idiot
you're gonna [ __ ] die on monday
you're fired on monday i don't think
that has anything to do with i mean
no i guess to be fair she does stalk
their uh their time
she does stop the dumbledore but i think
i think she just praying for their
downfall you know like sometimes
you just it's like stalking your it's
like
she's just she just wants to watch them
all their careers crash
i don't think they are she tries to tell
herself they are but they're all doing
really well
so they're all all their careers are
dying like no they're all crushing it
because she's not evil she's doing it
because she's hurt of course
that's what i'm saying i know that okay
i know you're saying that's not part of
it i just think it's funny
you're gonna get
well don't be stupid okay
trish doesn't even respond we got her
all on soundbites
well we'll see because next week or i
mean on friday we have another call-in
from the guy
who um was tricked into making out with
jason
and uh he's very upset about his
treatment in the vlogs
both racial jokes and the thing i can't
speak to the racial jokes that
he'll tell us how he feels about that
but being tricked into making fun of
making out with jason is really
disgusting i would be upset by that
also you made him such a fool like
without your consent
and then you don't know what's going to
happen and then you say oh don't put
that in the vlog
and then he does anyway it's like what
the [ __ ] is this why you would like
you know you're here to like get all
this attention and get all these views
and get all this exposure
and david just he he uses your eagerness
to be a part of something big and great
he uses that to [ __ ] stomp on your
face and humiliate you a b
but do you really think he didn't have
consent for that like even if he's not a
good person
he said he he said he did not give
consent he said that in his video
the guy that he said i did not give
consent for that to happen
so are you calling him a liar
yeah i'll call that guy liar all right
here we go let's get it on
let's see what he has to say av i
appreciate it
why would you call him a liar i
appreciate your your willingness i
believe nick and trisha
are sincere
not a guy not seth you're full of [ __ ]
[Music]
this is interesting ab is not willing to
pull the punches
okay what's your problem with this other
guy who's coming calling in on friday
i don't have a problem i don't know what
the [ __ ] he is he was he was barely in
the i mean like he was
he was in videos but i don't know
he
i'll talk it out with him
okay how's he gonna make an exposed
video like like i don't want to talk on
race it's not my place
but i'm how's he gonna make an exposed
video saying that dave david set him up
to do all these things and he was part
of it and he perpetuated it
and then he's still making videos like
that wait hold on hold on
the one that really disturbed me was the
kissing one i don't know anything about
the race ian or somebody can you pull up
the kissing video
and then his response to it because this
to me is really disgusting
it makes my skin crawl he says he did
not have consent to that a b says
he's a liar they did it twice
did it twice same two people okay all
right interesting so
you know more about this than me uh-huh
god you're gonna get killed in the
comments baby
maybe i have a problem trying to see the
good in people i don't know
well wait if you're trying to see the
good in people what about the guy coming
up
yeah he's saying he was abused
why not death yeah did you see the good
in seth
what what what email did he email us
you're just an empath
you are an empath yeah that's it
you know what it is i'll tell you
exactly what it is i can't be canceled
because
i have joker brain
you can't you can't play that insanity
card right now but
i only have one did you find it good let
me let me look into this
you asked me about defending you you
asked me this on friday after the uh
after we went off the air you said how
come you know you defend these people
what is what is that saying you
you i defended you i'm defending david
yeah i thought about it yeah yeah
and my knee-jerk reaction just goes oh
that's you know just have to be people
that i believe in
but i believe it's in these situations
it's that they're being told
one-sided all those situations we don't
know
david you know what i mean we don't know
david like no
no david right but but there are so many
people
like i said who are in that crew who are
still loyal to him to this day
you're right i mean that that does
that is a point and that doesn't
necessarily mean that all this stuff is
wrong but it doesn't mean that that the
criticism isn't valid
it doesn't mean that it's not toxic you
know right i'm not saying that he's not
the most evil [ __ ] ever lived
i'm not even saying that i'm just saying
that
but here's the bed maybe i'm
good at first this is the guy that's
calling in on friday that apparently
abey's room i don't know if he's calling
in anymore
what's going on it's coming over
oh it's the joke that they're both black
and they just have a secret handshake
yeah i mean that's fine i mean you know
why i don't know don't ruin this for me
okay
this is alex you probably already know
[Music]
do you want
something to drink
come on
i thought we were just saying what
is this the makeup one i think it's all
in here
why they just use this guy as a token to
make a bunch of black jokes you said
he's not in the vlog about um
a lot it seems like every scene he's in
is just making some kind of
black joke he's more dom's friend found
out my friend
seth has a warrant for his arrest and
this is oh this was so [ __ ]
you cannot dude he they took him to the
police station
and forced him to turn himself in i'm
not defending this but i am curious you
know why would you set me up like this
what are you doing to me
why did you send this video but you just
but you just go along with it because
you're on that because you're on that
clout
i gotta get that clown wait what are you
guys saying i'm not following okay
so today in this video they find out he
has a bunch of parking tickets
and they drive him to the police station
and force him to turn himself in
yeah he's stationed you're breaking the
only friend
and what he does is he pays off all the
tickets which is nice but
i think it it's very traumatic and i
i don't think it's worth discounting
like the fear of police of
of a young black man
yeah i'm gonna be pretty straightforward
okay [ __ ] what
every scene he's in is just playing on a
black stereotype going to the police
station to turn you in
i know that's what i thought don't worry
officers we got it from here
but you're joking right we're not going
to the police station the amount of
overcrowding in jails right now
you'll get out in a couple weeks we're
here at the los angeles police
department
what the [ __ ] is going on it's not funny
you want me to go in with myself
i'm not going in there i have warrants
so alex has a scary old man-master
they actually the fact that they
actually get him to do it just shows the
the amount of uh yeah the amount of
of peer pressure that they can exert on
someone it's like supernatural
that's why he has to become more
responsible
it has a lot of power over people it's a
power dynamic yeah
and you don't want to let david down
because you're out i bet that's the
vibe it's like you don't want to let
david down you don't want you have to be
up for anything or you're [ __ ] out of
the
squad you know what's not fair
the fact that netflix hides thousands of
shows from you based on your location
and then has the nerve to increase their
prices on you
that's right starting at the end of this
month they're raising their prices once
again
now you could just cancel your
subscription in protest or you could be
smart about it
and make sure you're getting your full's
money's worth by using
expressvpn see you might not know what's
on netflix in your country
see you might not know that what's on
netflix in your country
is completely different from what
someone else in the uk or japan has on
theirs
using expressvpn i can control which
country i want
netflix to think i'm in expressvpn has
over 90 countries to choose from so
every time i run out of stuff to watch
i just switch to another country to
unlock new shows
right now i watch i'm watching what are
we watching on netflix right now
murder mountain are you liking that
weird murder mountain [ __ ]
right now i'm watching dude japan
netflix is off the chain they have like
studio ghibli they've got all this anime
it's off the freaking rails bruh us
netflix ain't got [ __ ] on japan netflix
that's where i'm at all day here's the
best part it's not just for netflix
you can use expressvpn to unlock shows
on other streaming services too
i like to use it to watch bbc iplayer
it's free and only available
in the uk expressvpn is also super fast
and works on your phone
laptop and even smart tvs so you can
watch your shows on the big screen with
zero buffering
so be smart stop paying full price for
steaming services only getting access to
a fraction of their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
h3
don't forget to use my link so you get
three extra months free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
h3 expressvpn.com h3 to learn more
last year showed us that you can never
know what life is going to throw at you
and you use credit cards to pay for
unexpected expenses
it can be overwhelming to manage that
debt take control with upstars so you
know exactly what to expect
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple
fixed monthly payment upstart finds
smarter rates with trusted partners
because they assess
more than just your credit score with a
five minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front
for loans from one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars
you can get approved the same day and
receive funds as fast as one business
day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start
with upstart find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments to date
when you go to upstart.com h3
that's upstart.com h3
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com h3
me undies valentine's day elo's
ovulating you know what time it is
she's not actually i'm just saying it's
valentine's day coming up you know what
time it is baby
romantic word no it's not it's not it's
funny though erase it
it's funny how much about it is you
let's talk about love
yep we're doing it if there's one thing
that got us through this past year
other than dog face vibe in the
fleetwood mac it is
love all the loneliest people at home
are they like not me
and that meaning gets extra cheesy for
valentine's day
we'll allow it despite everything we
found new ways to match our daily lives
together with the ones we love most and
that's why me
undies released their v-day collection
in undies
loungewear and more so you and your
valentine can match through it all
show that special someone how much you
care and say those three words
everybody wants to hear match my undies
not ela is ovulating
and if you're single no problem show
yourself some love that's sad
i'm sorry show yourself some love and
something that makes you feel amazing
because you deserve that
well you want to sit alone in
valentine's day underwear
yeah why not sorry that's just sad
it's cute though if you buy like your
girlfriend or your boyfriend matching
undies that's cute as [ __ ]
definitely getting laid if you do that
you could probably have a good
jerk sesh alone in your own valentine
underwear like
i'm just so sad though
you could jerk off alone in your me
undies underwear
anyway me and these are made with
sustainable breathable softer than
soft fabric and available in a range of
sizes from
extra small to 4xl for fat it's really
soft for big fat [ __ ] like me
this is the worst coffee ever meandy's
membership gives you and your boo a new
pair of undies or socks every month
members get discounted pricing on
everything meundies makes as well as
early access to major print launches
come on you better buy [ __ ] because of
this read is also off the hinges
don't get us dropped by me on these you
all better go buy some [ __ ] this time
support the niche me undies has a great
offer for our listeners for any first
time
purchase you get 15 off and free
shipping mandy's also has their problem
free philosophy if you're not 100
billion
satisfied with any product for any
reason they'll refund or exchange it
no caveats no questions boom nothing to
lose forget no gaps
just like the kids say
did i say this myandy's membership also
gives you you and your boo a new pair of
my undies and socks every month
did i say that members get discounted
prices on everything mendes makes as
well as early access to major print
launches
me undies okay get fifty percent off
your free
your first order and free shipping go to
meundies.com h3 that's me
undies dot com slash h3 and guys please
this
if you do not buy if you don't support
we're gonna get dropped because this was
not a good read
i mean it was good but it was just a
little off the rails
i think they're good though they like
the weird raids right yeah
okay shout out to me on dude shout out
to me andy's family good sport yeah we
love them
all right see you guys at the show
thanks appreciate you
thank you thanks
he's been using to scare people for a
while now i'm going to convince seth
that he needs to make out with karina
while she's wearing that old man mask
beth are you okay with making out of
karen yeah that's fine karina's gonna
come out of my room before she has the
mask on and she's gonna show me how
weird she looks in her outfit
by the way why would they even do this
to seth if you say he's not even a big
part of the vlog squad like why are you
[ __ ] with this random dude who's just
coming to hang out i tell her that it
does look weird and then i need to go
and add some more padding to make her
look more like an old man
i gotta put pat and you look kind of
dumb but instead of going to the room
and adding more padding karina is going
to hop
out of the outfit and have jason put it
on instagram
jason is
the stuff with jason and in those bits
one i did not consent to those things
i did not david also shouldn't have done
it period
it's not right so he has a lot to say
about that apparently
maybe cancel david for for the
black humor i'm all in but i just i
believe this guy is
is full of [ __ ] because he's still doing
it after like what do you mean he's
doing it after
he's still doing like that he's still
posting tick tocks where he's like oh
i'm gonna steal this because i'm black
like he's still making no what about the
making out thing
oh the making out thing well he he they
did another video like that that's like
that's like saying you know
rappers say the n word so i can't say
that he's making racial jokes about
himself it's different but i don't care
i'm not even talking about the racial
thing because you can say he consented
or whatever
but the making out thing that's [ __ ]
up you gotta you gotta just
give david a check um an x on that
if that's real that's [ __ ] the most
horrible thing i've ever seen what do
you mean if it's real
why are you just not believing him how
did he
think okay i just is david like this
super secret mastermind or is he just
this dumb kid
who's just doing stupid [ __ ] because he
did this to this guy twice
with the same person would you say what
do you mean twice i see once what was
the second time
he did i was looking for it right now
i'm seeing a reaction video of it but
you're saying maybe you mentioned
earlier why did i send this whole
compilation because david has scrubbed
this from
the internet anywhere so we have this
montage
oh and by that's right man why don't you
time stamp this one
wait hold on hold on that's a good point
ian and by the way
when i was showing some of this before
it was getting blocked worldwide by
david dobrik
trying to bury his skeletons huh
why don't you believe this guy i find
that so odd why are you simping for
david when this guy literally is out
here saying i did not consent to that
listen to this listen to him
dude he's like hardcore making out with
a dude i mean that's it
with jason and and those bits one
i did not consent to those things i did
not
david also shouldn't have done it period
you i what's did not believe
it happened twice like so
okay so go on
why do you think he's lying this is why
david will never be held
the guy was in there the same guy that
was in that situation he's saying i did
not consent what else do you need
i don't understand but he thinks he's a
liar i don't know why well then you're
just
victim shaming i'm i'm saying that
everyone all david's
let's just support the abuser over the
victims are set up
all his
[Music]
the second time because he thinks he's
gonna make out with the girl i mean what
they told him
if it happened the second time it's
probably because david thought he
he saw he wanted to [ __ ] with them again
and show how dumb he is because then he
could do it to him a second time he and
just send a link
oh we got a link he said it's already
because i think it's been scrubbed but
this is a reaction video to it so oh
not too long after that i had an idea to
pull the prank on him again so i thought
it would be fun to blatantly ask him for
consent do i have permission to try to
prank you again and get you to make out
with jason i'm very confused by that
because how the hell gives be so
confident to
tell me that i have to consent to
something that
i'm not gonna know that i'm gonna do
that's not how we were gonna do it
that wasn't yet that wasn't a yes
right not yes
lab to see if they would help me make a
fake beef jerky commercial we created a
fake production company that created a
fake script so we're about to send out
this email to seth
for this beef jerky commercial he did
however say in david's defense
i'm gonna try to get you to make out
with jason again and he didn't say
no so
there's that real we're offering 2500
dude these reactors don't even exist to
me it's not interesting
like these people made a whole [ __ ]
video and like i'm not i don't even know
they're there
like what are they doing what kind of
content is this
i don't even [ __ ] know they're there
bro in fact can i just zoom in
on the day on the little video on video
watch i won't even realize they're there
[Laughter]
this is awesome okay
where will we
and within two days seth responded to
his fake audition with a real audition
we gave it a couple hours and then we
gave him a call with some really
exciting news
welcome to the beef jerky family man
we're super super excited
a couple days later it was time for the
shoot so we hired three women to play
the sexy sass watches so that set
wouldn't notice when jason switched out
with one of them
crew members along with the director
producer assistant director
crew and audio technician and this was
all happening while the rest of us sat
in a tiny trailer outside the house
watching us every move on a tiny screen
we wanted to make sure that seth
believed the commercial was real so we
shot it just like it was planned
this is how it turned out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
damn that's bomb beef jerky oh yeah he's
sitting on the couch he's loving the
jerky
he's passed out and now he woke up in a
love bed
silk sheets oh a hot monkey
suit comes and starts feeling them by
monkey it's beef jerky
what's the monkey got to do with that
okay sasquatch i think oh sashquatch so
the monkeys are making out he's having a
monkey threesome
it's hot it's happening
there's a monkey entering the stage oh
he's got his he's bearing his head and
the monkey tits pretty
elaborate they are really [ __ ] with
this guy there's like a whole room of
people in the back watching
who is that is that what jason so jason
gets in and starts like full on making
out with them
[Applause]
it's so good super hot
white super sexy super satisfying sexy
why is he making up so hard yeah the
beef jerky commercial
i understand but yeah they're getting
way too into it
that's what i'm saying though it's cool
you think it's fake who would believe
this
interesting you guys are the masters of
calling out fake pranks i mean
yeah yeah it doesn't look that
believable
yeah wouldn't he be paranoid too after
right and david's there filming why is
he involved in the beef jerky
let's see the reveal it's a prank
brother
that is insanely elaborate i have to say
[Applause]
well we'll have to get his perspective
on friday that's interesting
mind you at the moment right now he has
15k
youtube subscribers all right let's not
talk like come on that doesn't matter no
i'm not talking about numbers i'm just
saying why would you
i i'm not i'm not expecting that that if
anything
goes to the point that he's by the way
these reactors have not said anything
they're literally sitting here i am
watching this video entirely independent
of them
it's amazing look at these idiots
they're not idiots okay fine i'm just
okay god bless them
with peace and love you haven't said a
[ __ ] word kind of content is this
um thank you for uploading though
because we couldn't find it anywhere
else exactly
we appreciate you uh we're um we're
past break time actually gotta go to
break but if they don't if he only has
15k subs that really just goes further
to the point that he's
willing to debase himself to points he
would never think
why would he think he's gonna be the
star of a beef jerky commercial why
would they cast him
out of that whole game yeah i'm sure he
feels dumb if it's
[ __ ] true me that this was going
to happen again
like i always respect the [ __ ] man
that keeps his word
how is that for you better the second
time
interesting has
maybe talking about the first time yeah
that second time i gotta give it to you
on abi i think i
thought hilo yeah i can see your point
that he
he probably knew what was happening when
he was making out with him the second
time
i don't think he was surprised right but
could we chalk that off to david's
manipulative
kind of peer pressurey stuff the first
time seemed to be legitimately like yo
what the [ __ ] was that
the second time he was playing into it
okay before before we move on since i'm
already being canceled oh my god okay
what's left of the audience i just want
to say i'm not victim shaming
i believe the numbers never have to be
in your favor you should come forward
i'm just saying
in this situation it's a little bit
unique
because they're all in like a prankster
house with a bunch of pranksters so i'll
have 20 cameras out
right i feel like they'd be a little bit
more aware that's all
god bless bye said boy 2005.
too soon god he was so steve the good
always die young
um we have ben shapiro who's going to be
calling in
in a little bit you know he had a lot to
say about
cardi b's last video wet ass p-word as
he
referred to it and she just put out a
new one called up
so i figured maybe it'd be fun to get
ben shapiro
to comment on it and you know
surprisingly he agreed to call in which
is pretty amazing it was like a big deal
you know
so that's really exciting so i wanted to
refresh everybody and kind of just
show the video first um obviously i
can't play the music because
i'll get claimed into oblivion but i'll
i'll read it for you guys i'll give you
my own rendition
anyway it's you know yadda yadda i said
my face
bomb ass type rack stack up
shack height jewelry on me flashlight
i've been lit since last night hit him
with that good good make a n-word act
right
broke boys don't deserve no p word
uh lots of sexual references as you can
imagine
if it's up then it's up then it's up
then it's stuck that's how the course
goes
she says that a punch i could make the
party hot i can make your body rock
[ __ ] say they [ __ ] with me chances
are they probably not
if i had a dick you'd probably lick it
like a lollipop
[Laughter]
she's saying she could turn me gay if
she had a dick ho
speaking cup cap finis hit him with a
karate chop
yadda yadda here's my favorite uh one
hilo
she says where does she say captain
knees oh i don't know what that is
who's speaking japanese i don't know i
think it's like cap like a lie but
japanese like japanese
wow the whole cap thing took over like i
feel like i
blinked for a second and everybody's
saying no cap what is that
i don't know if that's what's being old
is yeah no cap
japanese talking about japanese
here's the best one and tell me if you
can relate yeah she says
um she says put it on him now
he will never be the same tatted on my
ass because i really like the pain
he nutted on my butt i said i'm glad you
came
if that n-word had a twin i'd let him
run a train
oh yeah sister
let's go so anyway that's kind of just
to give you the gist of it
and so i listen i'm a fan of cardi b
i think she's expressing herself she's
breaking norms and conventions and i
think it's fantastic now
ben shapiro i know was outraged by wet
ass p word
right so i'm sure he has a lot to say
but apparently
is he on the phone dan uh yeah he just
dialed in
uh ben are you there ben shapiro yeah
yes i am
this is ben shapiro hello to everyone at
age three oh well first of all
ben thank you for calling in i know
you're very busy
uh so thank you for taking the time to
call in the show i mean it's an honor to
to have you on yeah yes thank you for
having me i know
most people are thrilled to have me call
into their podcast says
it is typically an honor yes it is thank
you very much
so ben i assume you've seen
cardi b's new video have you um
i mean are you planning any to make any
youtube videos about it to make any
tweets or what do you plan what's your
thoughts on cardi b's
up uh well quite frankly ethan
i feel like i feel very compelled to
actually tweet about it and make some
videos
just because of how how vulgar it is and
how offended i am
you are it just it's just watching it it
just made me
you know i don't know very uncomfortable
i should say
very uncomfortable what about it i mean
it's just it seems pretty typical
pop song guy well well first uh
not only are the lyrics extraordinarily
vulgar but the video itself
i mean you know the words can't even
just describe it and there are a couple
things when you look at the lyrics some
of them don't even make sense
i mean the host speaking japanese hidden
with karate chop at first off they're an
estimated 7000 languages on earth
and being somewhat proficient in the
majority of these i can assuredly say
japanese is not a spoken dialect on this
planet and trust me
well ben ben i think she's she's kidding
i think it's
just like this thing called humor it's
just
japanese is no cap and so they're saying
japanese it's just a joke ben
okay well she needs to be clear about
that before putting something like that
on here it's going to be reaching out
right she should be more clear about it
right you're right
she should say she should put this
is a joke this isn't a real language
right instead and again you know like i
said it mortified i mean there's another
line in here as well
a lot of it just doesn't make sense
racks stack up shack height
i mean the generally given figure for us
currency thickness is point zero zero
four three interest
right exactly 85 inches tall or seven
foot one right if you
deck 100 bills to the height of shaq
that would be 19
772 or almost 3 million dollars right i
mean
considering my net worth is upwards of
20 million dollars
um you know up up more than a few shacks
but you don't see me making hippie hops
about it
right well again i think she's just it's
just a euphemism but
she does have a lot of money so it's
possible
right you know i mean i have a lot of
money too again but you know you don't
see me getting on the
live podcast you know bragging about it
or anything so you think she's being too
braggadocious about it
well well i i mean i would say so by
giving like i said by the lyrics and
and when you when you count the numbers
up it really doesn't even make a whole
lot of sense
you know to really say something like
that right okay i see your point sure
she we we should add a disclaimer to
that one too
saying maybe that you know the thickness
of u.s currency
generally this this isn't an accurate
representation it's just more of a
an analogy would that make you happy if
that it was like a disclaimer
i think it would make me happy again
like i said i mean these are songs that
are going out to millions of people hey
you need to be clear card
right okay right i mean is there
anything else in the song that
strikes you well you know one other
thing i
will say this when she says broke boys
don't deserve no p word
that is actually correct because broke
and
people in general do not deserve as much
as the rest of us like i said i'm worth
20 million dollars
oh so you agree that baroque bro boys
don't deserve any p word because
they're not they're interesting you have
this in common with cardi b you believe
that
poor people don't deserve what the
what rich people get because they
haven't worked hard enough exactly
exactly that's exactly what i believe so
like i said for them i do agree with
them
oh okay well you've got i'm glad you
guys found some common ground that is
that's great to hear
ben i'm very happy are you maybe
becoming a cardi b
fan in uh light of this uh common ground
well you know what i will say this i i'm
glad to find that com that found that
common ground with her
uh but the music videos are still a
little more vulgar for my tastes
so i'm not entirely sure we'll have to
see what she keeps producing um
that is that time will tell there
interesting
i see that you're outraged there's a
couple of things
it seems the most like technicalities
that have really pissed you off
ben what did you think about the one
where she says
um if he had a twin if the n-word had a
twin i'd let him run a train on me did
you have any thoughts because that
that's my favorite line in the song oh
boy
oh boy where do i start with that one
okay well first off a standard freight
train
such as no gauge mixed locomotive can
weigh anywhere from 4 000 to 20 000 tons
or 44 million pounds right so if you
were ran over by a train you would
likely be dead
right but ben a train is it's not she
doesn't literally mean being run by a
train it's
it's when you let multiple men have sex
with you that's what it means a train
it's a sexual reference ben well again i
don't understand how
from these lyrics you're supposed to
decipher something like that right right
right right
right i can see why you don't like it
because you just seemed like you're
missing the point of
most of the lyrics you know right well
let's just make the ricks i mean just
make them more straightforward and they
wouldn't have to guess you know and
don't make them as as explicit and maybe
they will be more straightforward
right i don't yeah that's a suggestion i
think you should listen to that
well she does have i mean she's doing
quite well on her own i'm sure she will
take into consideration your feedback
though ben okay well ethan i will say
there's another line in here that really
just irks me yeah it is
tell that [ __ ] back back red smell like
horse sex and
there's a few things first off you know
equestrian procreation fluid is actually
a very rare and highly sought after
commodity in a gallon of
gold star horse semen can cost up to 4.7
million dollars
it is actually the most expensive liquid
you can buy so
to back up who smells like horse sex is
actually a very low iq thing to do
something that i would not do so you
it's almost a compliment you're saying
if it smells like horse sex that's
that's a compliment
yes i'd advise you to get closer and
tell me more
right right right right right that's
true
yeah so i mean like i said the line it
goes with the rest of the lyrics how
they just don't add up
it really bothers me um so you know that
that line really really bothered me
yeah i i get that on that point i mean
horse semen is very valuable like you
said so maybe
maybe she could revise that line for
sure
i agree i completely agree i hope you're
watching this
and and i hope you are taking my
feedback to heart okay
well ben i i appreciate the analysis
that was really good
i mean uh yeah it's it's what i do
when you have an iq as high as mine you
know it is i enjoy breaking things down
such a song right uh-huh i understand
that i
i i admire your intelligence and your
analytical spirit very humble
very your humility very much you you
know so thank you ben shapiro wow ben
shapiro calling into the h3 podcast
fantastic we love it wow what a treat
thank you ben thank you for having me
all right you're welcome appreciate it
all right wow ben shapiro is a very
intelligent guy he had a lot to say
about that cardi b
song yeah a lot of comments back that
was fun though needs to revise
you know just occurred to me a b when we
were on the call with um
with ben shapiro maybe next episode you
can mount a defense for the holocaust
maybe that was misunderstood at all i
wasn't expecting to be here next week
but i'll make it you thought you're
gonna be cancelled
or murdered roasted alive yeah or do you
do you prefer to uh
mount the defense of the holocaust or
perhaps like uh apartheid south africa
or maybe i don't know i have to get
through this comment
i have to get through trisha next week
he may not survive today yeah good point
we appreciate you though
we honor your sacrifice god bless
so i the next topic here actually before
we get into free brittany because that's
what's up next and free britney [ __ ]
leave britney the [ __ ] alone
i'm full on team brittany after i watch
that documentary
i'm so happy that it came out because i
think
he was right the whole time right
we all made fun of him and we all made
fun of brittany and he was the only one
trisha thinks she's a britney stance she
got nothing on that dude
um for the longest time i've been seeing
this free britney
like trend every here and there and i
even asked you guys at one point should
we talk about it and we like
we just weren't sure like the data
wasn't easy to understand what's
happening
i'm just happy that there finally is
something official to watch
the new york times i mean it doesn't get
more official than that yeah you know
they do the research oh yeah
so um so
yeah i think it's it's a lot i feel much
more informed to talk about it now where
before it was like
this is this and that is that and i
don't know who to trust and you know but
now i feel like the new york times did a
really good job
and now i'm fully confident in saying
free britney and leave
brittany alone but before we do that we
wanted to watch
jesus he's right though everyone was
treating her like this
and he that was part of the
documentaries that people treated her
like
like not a human being and and and he
was right
maybe a little less hysterical but
but granted apparently this i saw this
and i thought this was fake you know mr
ponton i believe
you have a filter turn apparently this
is a 100 percent legit
a a turn look at the eyes looking at the
corner all right you're not giving an
adjustment
okay so this is a court hearing over
zoom because of covid
and the one of the uh attorneys
calls in with a cat filter on and he
doesn't know how to turn it off
now i saw this was like come on this
can't be real and i immediately
dismissed it but
more has come out and it turns out that
um
whoa whoa whoa read this recording of
this hearing or live stream is
prohibited
violation may constitute contempt of
court and result in the fine of 500
or jail how the [ __ ] is 500 equivalent
to 180 days in jail
i'll pay the 500.
somebody [ __ ] up who recorded this
but it's been all over everywhere but
i'm saying but literally it says
recording this is illegal
so who did it was it the cat guy or the
judge
i'm gonna blame the opposing lawyer this
guy doesn't seem that slick he doesn't
know the request i don't know
look at this guy he's trying to uh he's
trying to get poor uh rod here in
trouble
anyway listen to how sad this situation
is
[Music]
mr ponton i believe you have a filter
turned on in the video settings
you might want to uh the eyes are
panicking
can you hear me judge yeah i can hear
you i think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to i
can't oh i'm prepared to go forward with
it
that's he says this is why i thought it
was fake
he said he wanted to proceed with the
cat filter
i was like there's no way and then his
voice is all like oh
how is this real i'm prepared to do the
case in the cat filter your honor
you're alive that's not i'm not a cat
i'm not a cat
nobody says that that's this is fake
we're being trolled
this can't be real this is fake nobody
says i'm not actually a cat
like this is fake i don't know
he's here live that's not i'm not a cat
he says i'm not a cat
i can see that okay um i think if you
click
the up arrow next to this
i'm calling fake on that one i don't
know who says i'm not a cat
he's a an attorney he's panicking you
can hear it i'm not a cat
you can't don't tell me it's fake even
if it's fake i don't want to know it's
fake because
anyways go ahead i have traffic court
coming up if i may say
and i want to do this
i got a speeding ticket for tick-tocking
while you drive
no no it was it was kind of a chicken
[ __ ] ticket but
how about traffic coming up i was going
57 and a 40. what
that's not that bad it's a chicken [ __ ]
ticket yeah
i got that exact tip how much the ticket
was 57 and a 40
years ago oh it's it's 418
wow pretty brutal yeah what'd you say to
the cop did you think you were gonna get
off and then he gave you the ticket
well i was i was on my way to go get a
covet test oh
and um he he just he hadn't
he didn't give a flying [ __ ] they're
trying to raise money man i heard
they're giving out tickets like crazy in
l.a
right now parking tickets and [ __ ]
ian you got a parking ticket you were
all pissed off l.a city's going
ham on that [ __ ] yeah i didn't even do
anything wrong
i followed all the signs and i had a
pass and they gave one to me anyway so
we got to dispute it how much is it
i think it's it might be about 80
dollars
it's right on the cusp of not being like
because you have to go through so much
[ __ ] to
dispute it right yeah everyone down that
whole line on the street all had passes
i saw them all in the window too so that
dude just like papered the whole street
and didn't give a [ __ ] just it's just so
thinking we all
can't be bothered you know it's so
[ __ ] up because
you know it's like ian's [ __ ] all
those people are [ __ ] and there's like
no recourse for the cop or the city for
giving out [ __ ] tickets and it was
now they all these people have this huge
[ __ ] mess to deal with
or just they're out 80 bucks because
some [ __ ] cop was [ __ ] around
pissed me off oh
oh uh vice uh has an article about the
cap filter thing it does appear to be
real
i ca dude they interviewed the lawyers
as there's a whole backstory to it how
could he say i'm not a cat
i mean i do not want his pet he's
freaking out he's freaking out he's a
lawyer damn get your [ __ ] together
well i'm not i'm prepared to go forward
as a cat
from what i'm doing that's
i've always heard that judges are
notoriously impatient with um
with lawyers yeah he's scared yeah he
might be just afraid that
the judge thinks he's wasting his time i
don't have patience for this cat
[ __ ]
i'm so doing this during my traffic
court you're gonna know
don't do it you're gonna get you're
gonna you're gonna get [ __ ] you're
gonna lose your license bro
i'm for the meme man that's great record
it just record yeah of course of course
of course
jack's going to lose his license man
you're going to be stuck with that it
would be worth it
be worth it for the [ __ ] live dude
all right
just record it it says in this article
that the uh the lawyer
had let his uh daughter use his laptop
to
to zoom and she had turned it on and it
was just left on and he didn't realize
it
it's totally real is there any info
about who recorded it
you know i just scanned the article i
didn't see anything about that are we
just going to ignore the fact that
somebody broke the law
yes it is interesting that i got a yes
anyway free britney all right
right i am so pro britney spears i first
of all if anyone has hulu go on hulu and
watch this
it's called new york times presents they
have a bunch of episodes of different
topics
this one was about free brittany it's an
hour 20 minutes long it's captivating
even if you don't care it's super
interesting her story
is so messed up um first of all
they go all throughout like how she
became famous and
you know when britney was being when she
was at like the height of her fame
the paparazzi industry was so crazy
they interviewed this guy i forgot what
magazine was but they had like a million
dollars a month budget they were paying
paparaz like the
the paparazzi business was so lucrative
and they were paying people so much for
candid photos that um
that's why there there were so many of
these vultures and why there's so many
people doing it you know they
interviewed one guy
who got this infamous photo of her like
all crazy with the shaved head when she
was attacking
his car with an umbrella i think he got
like a million bucks for that photo
and um
i mean they these paparazzi really
ruined her life
also it was interesting for me to see
how
she came to the success like i had no
idea that
she was so young and it happened so fast
she was just
really talented that's crazy so the
story is like basically her dad is not
very involved in her life
he's really since the very beginning
just interested in the money
her mom is there for her and when she
has this
so the the lead up to this whole mental
breakdown was interesting too because
what happened was these paparazzi are
like let me show you some of this these
um
here's the here's an excerpt actually
from the documentary she was with her
cousin
ally so she trying to get away from the
paparazzi
went with her cousin ally in a normal
car and somehow this guy got a tip so
also he was so he was describing how
he was following her throughout the
night and he was
aware that she was having a horrible
night her ex-husband
was denying her to see the kids he took
full custody of her kids which is like
insane uh you can only imagine a single
mom losing cuss full custody
seems like the courts [ __ ] her like
throughout this whole time
so this guy is following her he's seeing
her trying to get to see the kids
getting denied
then going again she's clearly having
like the worst night of her life and
he's still following her
and the whole i think the whole reason
she shaved their head was like um
just in defiance of all these paparazzi
yeah to say
like you got nothing to see here she was
with
your cousin ally
i looked at brittany from the windshield
and i was videotaping her and i said
how are you doing you doing okay look at
this guy filming her
like look at this i'm concerned about
you
right in a while it's like it's just
it's so [ __ ] up we go back to kevin
featherline's house
she buzzes the door again he doesn't
open the gate
well now she's upset i love how this is
somehow his story to tell her private
business just because he's the one
stalking her
so they pulled behind a jiffy lube store
i go to the car i tell brittany hey
brittany
all i'm going to do is i'm just going to
ask you a couple of questions
and then i'm going to leave you alone
and ally's coming up to me and she's
like guys please please
please don't stop no guys please please
guys and brittany
just grabbed the umbrella started coming
after me
and starts beating the passenger side of
my truck
[Music]
that night was not a good night for her
oh wow she did that too it was not a
good night for us
it was a great night but it was a good
night for us because it was a money shot
that's the thought of that infamous
photo he took
and so she's always on the front line of
these like i mean
there's this one photo that you showed
me you love like there's like literally
yeah where is that one maybe you can
find it
i mean you have an album here maybe but
i'm not sure this one's it's in this one
there's uh
yeah like i remember
they talked about this photo where she
has her newborn baby in her lap
and everyone's trashing her that she's
such a bad mom and it's unsafe but when
she talks about it
she's like look the paparazzi were all
up in my [ __ ]
i was trying to put my baby in my seat
they were just in my [ __ ] face it
wasn't a safe situation
so i just put him on my lap and drove
around the corner you know it's like
it makes sense but on the cover of the
tabloids it's like brittany's a horrible
mom she's not responsible she can't have
this
kid anyway all the stress of
being hounded by the paparazzi and
losing custody of her kids she
checked into a like mental
rehabilitation
center and then when she did that all of
a sudden out of the woodworks comes her
dad who was never involved in her life
that he was never really involved and
comes out
and makes this really bizarre play
to take control of her entire
estate finances and
entire well-being called a conservat
conservatorship conservatorship
conservatorship
conservatorship now the conservatorship
i sent the pictures on what's up you got
it
um is usually for like old people who
are old and senile and can't manage
their own affairs because
they're likely to be scammed or frauded
or they're incapable of making their own
decisions right
so it's a very drastic
uh decision look at this this is her
[ __ ] life
i didn't can't even tell where she is
where is she in the middle it's like a
hard to even
you gotta zoom in but which person is
she oh here um
no i think it's like where's waldo
let me look on my phone well he listens
anyway
yeah there yeah
so this was like her life all the time i
mean you see paparazzi now that those
people didn't have [ __ ]
on what it used to be because of the
amount of money that was being paid out
to them
for these tabloids
so
um so her dad comes out and makes this
really drastic claim over her
whole personship and at the time when i
learned all this into the documentary
britney said i understand the need for
this conservative conservatorship
conservat conservatory
conservatory conservatorship
conservatorship
yeah something about the tur to the ship
conservatorship
is that right come on man all right joe
take it easy
you're the king of gaps she says i
understand the name
come on joe i'm being serious
i understand the need for the
conservatorship she says
i just don't want my dad i want a third
party
who will you know be coming from a
neutral standpoint like i don't trust my
dad i don't want him
in charge so she hires a really good
attorney to represent her interest
and the judge says
you are not fit to retain counsel
because of your mental state and she
said you
and the judge said she can't have her
own [ __ ] attorney
which is so crazy
so they appoint her an attorney
i don't know who or what or who they are
what they're doing i mean it could just
be a court-ordered attorney those these
are not good attorneys
i mean for the most part these are just
people working their way up
and so she gets [ __ ] over by the court
she can't hire her own attorney
her dad takes over all of her finances
all of her person all of her
like everything she does everything
she's offered everything goes through
the data for example the new york times
said
we wanted to interview brittany and we
sent a request four times and we were on
it's unclear if she ever even received
the invitations
crazy part is that they can even book
work for her
they book work for her he's getting a
cut by the way
of he's getting that he told the court
he wanted 2.5
of all the proceeds and they approved it
and then there was a point where he was
asking for a raise
and it's like clearly the the motives
are there's a conflict of interest
and all she wants is a third party she
just wants her dad out
and so everything she does that's why
there's like all these conspiracy
theories about her instagram and all
these cryptic
posts is because everything in her life
is has to be approved
and so that's why people think she's
hiding all this [ __ ] in her instagram
which i'll show you guys some of those
posts in a moment but
um pretty they interview a lot of people
close to brittany who work with brady
and none of them have anything nice to
say about the dad
one of her business managers something
at one point said the only interaction i
ever had with jamie spears her dad
was him saying my little girl's going to
be rich someday and she'll buy me a boat
he's like that's all i'll say about
jamie spears
and so even today she's in this
conservatorship
she keeps trying to sue the
conservatorship is
permanent she keeps trying to sue to get
him out
just to get him out maybe you sent me
something here
what is this my client has informed me
that she is afraid of her father
his her court yeah court appointed
lawyer told the judge
why the [ __ ] so then like there's this
huge paradox
because all the time that she's in this
conservatorship which
the whole basis of allowing this is that
she's incapable of
managing her affairs that she's like
she can't even hire a lawyer i mean that
is [ __ ]
and so all the time she's going on tour
she's going on tv she's doing shows
she's making new music
these are all the actions of a highly
competent person that doesn't need to be
in a
uh conservatorship and so it's like this
paradox it's like
is she or is she not at one point they
refer to her in court as a high
functioning conservatorship it's like
what the [ __ ] does that mean
and then later on they try to say they
tell the judge they want to hurt the
judge to think about it as a
conservatorship
slash business
relation yeah and the judge is accepting
all it's disgusting it's
[ __ ] disgusting i think the fact that
she's so
[ __ ] up is somehow able to perform
alone
will tell you she is capable exactly the
whole
performing is really difficult what else
what else if you're not capable of doing
anything
you shouldn't be able but this has been
going on for years like when did this
conservatorship start like
this is still going on she had a hearing
like last
year where she was still denied like her
dad's
is still on the thing you know
and also it was implied that they
dangled
custody of her kids over her like having
she had the consent to this otherwise
they would deny her custody of her kids
i would like this judge to be
investigated because i don't trust this
motherfucker's judge
how is he granting them continually over
and over
the conservative ship started in 2008
so now it's i mean she's it's been 13
years
you know and she's under the thumb of
her dad and some [ __ ] lawyer
it's meant i've never heard of anything
like it my whole [ __ ] life
you really have to watch this
documentary it's disgusting it's just
it's
horrible and then
leading up to her initial mental
breakdowns was her
relationship with um justin timberlake
who totally [ __ ] justin timberlake's
getting dragged on social media because
i feel like he totally
did her so dirty you know let me see
here's the part
here's the club discussing justin
timberlake
i just felt so horrible for the whole
way through
to be very high school about it was like
she was the school [ __ ]
my friend he was like the school
quarterback or whatever and
he essentially weaponizes the video for
one of his singles to
incriminate her in the demise of the
relationship
[Music]
he made this whole huge single talking
about how she cheated on him
which by the way hasn't she apparently
all these guys the documentary
indicates that that didn't happen nobody
knows why they broke up but he's putting
this whole thing that he
she cheated on him which doesn't seem to
be any proof of that and then this when
he went on the radio and did this this
this really pissed me off you could put
the sound back then
there was a revenge uh pure male revenge
fantasy
justin timberlake is in the house and i
just want to ask you one question
did you britney spears
so at the time she was making a whole
big deal about saving her virginity for
marriage because she's like a
christian and um yeah
oh man come on man
it's so creepy it's just [ __ ] up you
know
it's not cool i don't know what can you
say about misogyny there's a whole
infrastructure
to support it and
when it's time for people to come stop
the clock
exclusive the straight guys who get rich
making gay porn
tell me more look at the headline of
this magazine can we ever forgive justin
timberlake for all that [ __ ] music
no we can never forgive him what the
[ __ ] what is this magazine
i think you know they're making they're
emphasizing the guy's point about the
entire uh
oh my goodness misogyny here roman
headed justin bieber i guess he was
trying to act like macho and reform his
cis no more [ __ ] music bro
i mean you got to remember he was uh he
was in sync right
yeah yeah in sync and i mean that was
you know a boy band
mostly girl fans so i think he was
trying to redo his image as not
a heartthrob trying to be badass
misogynistic culture
for a woman there's a whole apparatus
ready to do it
anyway
the most it's so upsetting this whole
conservatory ship
that it's still going on to this day you
know
but let's look at some of her instagram
posts um
her instagram is so bizarre it's just
it's so bizarre and because like it's
like she wants to say certain stuff but
she can't because people need to approve
her posts
so let me show you some of the some of
the truly bizarre
things here i should say that uh her
social
media team made a statement stating that
that's not true that she has full
control
of her social media yeah i believe that
why does she have a social media team
well i mean most big stars do
i'm not saying that that's i mean that
could be a lie i'm just i'm putting that
out there
and her dad says it's all fake too so
what's the point they work for her dad
they work for the conservatorship fair
enough
leave brittany alone i'm just putting
the facts on the table
yeah i mean obviously every everybody
denies everything you know
her dad denies it
her brother tried to go on the radio and
deny it and he made it sound way worse
he goes on
and he goes is every it's all played out
i mean obviously britney off
always wanted to get out of the
conservatorship
he said that on the radio in a really
weird interview it's like
why are you keeping her in that against
her will then right
so here's one here's i'm just gonna
these are some instagram posts that
stood out to us
they're all so weird dude
so this one's concerned about me
apparently
as well my family has been going through
a lot of stress and anxiety lately so i
just need a time to deal
but don't worry i'll be back very soon
hi guys just checking in with all of you
who are concerned so that's it okay but
then she wrote a huge message
saying just just to take out some
moments don't believe
everything you read are here my
situation is unique but i promise i'm
doing what's best at this moment
it's all so cryptic exactly i think
they're dangling custody over her kids
right from i really do
um so this one was so weird dude you
tell me this isn't [ __ ] weird
so in a previous post somebody said if
you need help wear yellow in your next
video in our next video this is our
outfit
really yeah
that's wild i was like oh [ __ ] that is
that is weird man
um this is one that people talked a lot
about i don't know how serious it is but
any more questions in the comments and
i'm here to answer all of your questions
so the first main question that you guys
have been asking me is what's my
favorite disney movie
my favorite disney movie is probably
frozen just because i really like the
fact that the two sisters
um their relationship and then one goes
off and lives in a castle just because
she can't deal
anymore um my favorite movie movie is
probably a
ferris bueller's day off um what time do
i go to sleep
i go to sleep between 11 30 and 12. um
what's my favorite flower
it's a rose and how old was i when i got
my first car
i was probably 17 years old somebody
said the fact that
this one's probably a stretch i'm gonna
i'm gonna say that
because one of them is locked up in a
tower
right the thing it was about her saying
that her favorite movie is frozen
honestly all these instagram things
they're all stretches i mean it's it's
people that
are super on board with this free
brittany thing but her social media is
so
very it is bizarre may this gracious
beautiful summer help us
all spread out wings and fly to where
our hearts truly desire
right so all of them they're
interpreting as if she's trying to she
wants to break free
well i don't even think it's a myth she
they said it all in the documentary that
she
hates it and she wants to get out she
they quoted her saying i thrive on
freedom and just be able to do my own
thing
like she clearly is [ __ ] miserably
stuck in this thing
she's being enforced by the court it's
an it's it's unbelievable i mean it's
just a total [ __ ] nightmare
um that's about it i mean
i guess there's really not that much
it's just here let's just pick one at
random and see
all been waiting for last week the super
bowl i was
so excited but honestly i was rooting
for kansas city but i was also rooting
for the other team so
it was a little confusing for me i love
sharing
the moment as opposed
you know
[Music]
all right all right you're right
i just i'm team free brittany i think
what's going on with her
is horrible i think the way she was
treated was horrible and now her
piece of [ __ ] dad is real it's just it's
so
the fact that this is happening in
america through our legal system
it's just it's abominable it's an
abomination of god
well hey it's infringing on on her on
her right of freedom
i mean look
you can't ask her to go on the road and
do shows and then say she's incompetent
to manage her own life it just doesn't
work that way
so free britney hashtag free britney
[ __ ]
no
so in 2020 the conservatorship was
extended four times and spirits
requested her father be removed
twice both times she was declined why
yeah i don't get why just put someone
else she's saying
puts an impartial party the conservative
ship was extended until september 3
2021 the court was supposed to review
how jaime handled spears assets
but decided to continue the discussion
next year why
why are you always kicking the can down
the road investigate this judge bro for
real
[ __ ] here here's a music clip of the
documentary talking about it
according to court records britney's
conservators are able to control who can
and cannot visit her
and retain security guards for her 24
hours a day
they have the power to access her
medical records and communicate with her
doctors
they can take control of her house and
even cancel her credit cards
they can make recording touring and tv
deals for her and are deeply involved in
her finances
how can you make a deal there's some
speculation that britney may have
basically accepted the conservatorship
because she was worried about seeing her
kids and a few weeks later she starts to
get some visitation rights restored
so so she finally exactly it just so
happens she finally gets visitation
rights
restored after that was the part that
really was so painful to watch she
he the ex-husband got full custody
it's so messy and she wasn't able to see
the kids at all i cannot imagine that
and a lot of the reason why it's
shown that she lost cussy it's because
of the media frenzy
always depicting her as like
irresponsible and crazy and the amount
of pressure and harassment they put on
her
and like documenting every moment um
did not give a partial hearing to that
so you know
[Music]
that's it that's my take free britney
[ __ ]
abe you watched it what'd you think
about it it was sad it was really sad
you know i grew up watching brittany and
uh
it's horrible yeah i know it seems like
out there at first but
i just can't believe there hasn't been
something made about it sooner
right i hope that the pressure
i hope she gets out i just want her to
get out of it i just want her to [ __ ]
i am i just think her dad is a total
scumbag and the fact that he's getting
away with this
for so long now 11 year or 12 years or
something it's cr
it's wild he's clearly just making a
fortune off her that's it
i don't know very very disturbing
you all want to talk about some yo
okay jared leto is back as the joker
this is a lot to take in i know
this is a lot to take in i don't know
who thought this would be a good idea
but he's getting his own movie right
like him and batman no no no no
this is part of the zack snyder
uh recut of the justice league
that are you serious anticipate yes so
tread lightly
wait this was this is the one lightly
the fans of which are uh
extremely zealous in their uh criticism
of any
um skepticism about the quality
wait this upcoming he's just remixing
the
yeah the so the story was he was
making the justice league because you
know he's been kind of in charge of the
whole dc
universe for a while now and during it
he had a tragic accident with his family
and had to leave production
and joss whedon took over and finished
the movie
and so after that there's been a
concerted effort
to pressure the studio to allow zack
snyder to
realize his original vision if you will
um which we are now getting in the form
so people really think this movie is
going to be good
some people do how can that be i don't
know
zack you you apparently think this looks
badass
uh i think the joker character looks
cool yeah i dig it
yeah i can't i like the simplicity of it
i like the long hair i like the darkness
of it
you're like oh you're like this is not
the joker i knew you were gonna say that
you like the long hair
this is the lamest joker ever conceived
i mean this is
so lame joker is starting to look more
and more like you zack
we have a convergence the joker brain is
converging they're getting some good
ideas man
did they get rid of the damaged tattoo
on his head i don't see that
god i realized that was too cringe
good oh wait i think i heard that he's
going to
this will be in a flashback of some kind
so they're basically just shoehorning it
in
from what it sounds like all right i'll
give it a shot but you all know it's
gonna be [ __ ] like don't even lie to
yourself
ian had an interesting suggestion the
other day when this comes out i think
we should definitely all watch it and in
particular
we want to hear ila's uh take on
the justice league that's a great idea
i'm a hater so
yeah which i'm gonna get canceled for
that one you listen everyone hate it
i mean look everybody knows well come on
jared leto joker
nobody needs that how long we've been
going dan i have
one more story i really want to talk
about uh we've been going a while
um it's probably hour 45 almost two
listen i have to talk about
listen i take no pleasure
in [ __ ] on joe rogan because
he has a cult that will literally
eviscerate me if i say anything bad
about joe rogan
but for the amount of alpha brain he
chugs in a day
you think you would be a little [ __ ]
white and all these smart people he
talks to do
you don't think you'd be saying such
dumb [ __ ] as this
okay i am just so not down with this
[ __ ] ape
brain ignorance he's smart he knows
better than just listen what he says
about the coveted vaccination
it really pisses me off you taking that
vaccine no
yeah no it's not like not
no that's cc it's like anyone who takes
that [ __ ] is a [ __ ] idiot
no i i just not [ __ ] i mean i would if
i felt like i needed it
but i just i just feel like if you
maintain your health
and i think for some people it's
important i think for some people it's
good
are they gonna are they gonna make you
you cannot be missing the point this
badly after all this time
it's not a question of if you need it we
all have to get the [ __ ] vaccine to
achieve herd immunity do you understand
that
people like you who are too lazy or too
[ __ ] dumb to understand it or to like
alpha you think of like
it makes you look like a [ __ ] if you
wear a mask or get a vaccine
you gotta [ __ ] chill on the elk meat
dude because it's rotting your [ __ ]
brain
you gotta come down to the earth for a
second because this is important joe
rogan
you need to get the vaccine because it
helps achieve her
immunity we all have to get it that's
the whole [ __ ] point
i mean what's so hard to understand
about it it's so [ __ ] simple
it's so basic it doesn't mean you're a
[ __ ] or a [ __ ]
doesn't mean have anything it doesn't
make you better joe don't worry we see
the muscles don't worry
yeah what you couldn't be wearing a
white
tighter shirt i could see your nips
through that boy and you know what i
mean
it's like barney frank nipples
protruding looking disgusting
all right what were you gonna say dan
i just um it confuses me because you
know he's had a lot of
experts about coven on his channel and
but moreover
uh you know he talks about all the time
he he gets
rigorous testing he has all the people
that come into his show
tested on the spot he has a doctor on
staff so it's not like he
he's not a covet denier he understands
it's a thing and and he's
doing he is taking something well he has
to do it to have the show go on and have
guests
right he acknowledges that it's real but
that's that's why
that's what's so confusing to me about
this is why was he missing the point
yeah it's so obvious you have to get the
vaccine
i just don't say like okay in someone's
brain who
shared this is this opinion how do you
guys think we're gonna get out of this
how are we gonna get out of this okay
you don't have to worry
and what the the elderly are gonna get
healthier that's the idea i don't
understand they're not healthy enough
they need to be
i guess maybe it's just the conception
that that
just just people that are vulnerable
need the vaccine and
if you're not vulnerable to getting
seriously ill you don't we were trying
to kill
this thing are trying to make it
disappear so it doesn't last
for [ __ ] ever and it comes around
every winter like the flu
we are trying to kill it like polio and
the only way to kill it is if we all get
vaccinated so it can no longer reproduce
i mean take some dmt or whatever to come
to this realization if you need to
it's pretty obvious i don't think you
need to alter your mind to come to such
a it's pretty [ __ ] basic but
to go into your deprivation tank take
some dmt meditate on the simple [ __ ]
fact
that you have to get vaccinated joe
rogan
i mean stop being so [ __ ] dense dude
i know your density is probably more
than like tungsten steel looking at you
but just try to open your mind a little
bit
he's such a [ __ ] ape and i mean he
already got [ __ ] from like bill burr and
a bunch of people because when
he said wearing masters for [ __ ] and
then he had to go on a whole apology
tour
literally was joking okay oh let me just
is this a joke what watch his knee jerk
reaction you taking that vaccine
no no it's like obviously not
and what disturbed me the most is i saw
this on tick tock with a poll and it
said are you getting the vaccine
and on this clip because joe rogan has
influence over people
70 of the people said no i'm not getting
the vaccine
yes you are being a selfish
ignoramus dude it's really annoying me
because in this case it's more than just
like
okay your body your choice like
obviously you have the choice to do
whatever you want but
your decision doesn't only affect you
what's so hard to understand
well this this this comment is going to
directly or well let's say
indirectly cause harm and death to
people
people take it in order to go overseas
i'm worried about that oh
so why are you worried about that just
take the vaccine you [ __ ] hate
it why are you worried about that to
think that you could get a vaccine
and fly safely he's clearly has some
conspiracy
if he was just worried that he doesn't
need it if it was just oh i don't need
it because i'm healthy
then he would know have no problem
getting it to fight tell you a little
story my mom got the vaccine and guess
what
in a month she's going to come visit us
i'm so worried about that
bro that sounds like a nightmare how are
you worried about taking a vaccine when
you eat dmt and your [ __ ] cheerios in
the morning
i'm finally going to be able to see my
mom after a year
oh my god we should all be so worried
this is bad news we got vaccines
bad news well he says some people can
get it it's just not for everybody
but that's but i think that's not the
idea i don't think he's being truthful
because if he wasn't worried about the
vaccine and some weird conspiracy he
would just get it to go overseas
why is he worried about having to get it
to go overseas yeah that's what i was
trying to say earlier is just like
it his position based off of his actions
really
like say he's going to go far enough to
say oh the vaccine is harmful
and people shouldn't get it well that's
not correct but at least that's like
a coherent point of view like yeah
people shouldn't get it because it's
going to harm you but he doesn't think
it's harmful
so why not just get it especially why is
he worried that he might have to get it
to go overseas
because he's a [ __ ] conspiracy
theorist idiot
he literally went on his show and tried
to say that the moon landing was fake
for like a whole year
oh he was on that for about a decade you
guys you guys
you guys this guy thought the moon
landing was fake okay he just
he never said it was fake just had a lot
of questions alpha brain
people do you don't even know what's an
alpha brain like what even is this [ __ ]
you're eating
and you're gonna tell me that the
vaccine isn't safe that was studied
by like multiple government agencies and
approved by the fda under rigorous
testing and this guy's taking some
[ __ ] formula that some dude in the
basement could stop
putting a [ __ ] pill called an alpha
brain
that has not been uh that alpha brain
has not been
uh i don't think it's about the fda can
[ __ ] sure as hell [ __ ]
guarantee that well let's fact check
that has it been uh
i'm looking yeah give me a second yeah i
doubt the fda is going to back up claims
that alpha brain
increases memory and [ __ ] and
jizz thickness i don't know if that's
one of their claims
is alpha brain fda approved answer the
united states fda
is not authorized to approve dietary
supplements
yeah they're not yet recognized because
the claims are [ __ ]
there's nothing about you can't prove
that it helps your memory
like it's not magical i think for some
people it's good i just don't know how
he's missing he's
he's doing so much damage like we need
to get on the same [ __ ]
patrons and all sick get here he talks
more about i don't also
i want to know how this how people fare
over x amount of months like what
happens in six months after the vaccine
when how long does it last for okay cool
so we'll have another six months of hell
and it'll probably get even worse
because it keeps
we keep getting the new um strain and
the new
whatever mutant [ __ ] uh [ __ ]
that's gonna destroy our life at that
point right okay let's wait just so that
you know
feels comfortable taking the vaccine
well first of all he's wrong it's
already been studied and approved
people have been taking this vaccine for
a year for himself
but he's wrong they have tested that
people have already been vaccinated for
over a year in these trials they've been
studied
closely these have been approved across
the globe as safe for human consumption
and by the way vaccines just like this
have already been been given to people
like this isn't bran this isn't some
crazy
uh off the books thing that's never been
used like apparently
this technology's been being used in
aids medicine uh for
a long time it's not like some it's not
like you're gonna like
what's the [ __ ] mystery this is tech
this is technology that exists dude
yeah and then so we're now we're in a
race against the clock with this new
variant from the uk which is supe
way more contagious and we have to get
vaccinated as soon as possible otherwise
this new
variant is going to take over and we're
going to be stuck
we're going to be stuck with coven
forever do you understand that's the
risk
if we don't get vaccinated soon enough
we're going to be stuck with kovid
forever
because joe rogan isn't [ __ ] scared
of it people like you know
in six months after the vaccine when how
long does it last for
what does it matter how long it lasts
for you get a booster like
you should be more worried about getting
covered same thing people don't know how
long you're gonna know
that you're not worried about it you
should be worried about [ __ ] other
people
like people 400 almost 500 000 people
have died of covet you don't care about
that
[ __ ] you it's just irresponsible he's
got such a huge platform people listen
to him
and it's just people look up to him
of course he's just this is just so rape
i mean it's just dangerous it's just
unsafe
dangerous it's not good this guy says he
shoots up roids but
the vaccine is too much right
showing his stupidity once again for all
of us to marvel at my sense of smell is
completely screwed up and it's been for
over a month
well your health was probably not good
imagine thinking at that
imagine thinking a deadly novel virus is
more appealing than a vaccine
you're probably not eating enough raw
meat yeah joe's whole thing is like
well if people are dying it's their
fault for being fat or something even
though it's just old mostly
age is the biggest indicator of risk of
death
age nothing else he's not totally wrong
about
if he got coveted he would probably
survive of course that's what i'm saying
that's not the point it's not the point
so not the point it's like okay
uh sorry then i don't care about your
mom i'm just gonna give you the virus
and you're gonna give it to your mom
but we'll be fine look it it's not even
it's all a chain reaction we are fluid
right you we have three
over 300 million people living in the
united states it's a fluid ocean you get
it
they get it you pass it on that's the
whole point it's not even about you give
it this that is
we all have to [ __ ] collectively come
together and get this vaccine
you know and then you've got people like
elon musk who's apparently a smart guy
i don't know what the [ __ ] he's on about
either it's like this whole alpha of
[ __ ] like it's like a contrarian it's
people who are like
natural contrarians just refuse to
[ __ ] listen to
elon musk talk about this you get a
vaccine are you
what do you do with your own family you
won't get a vaccine why is that
i'm i'm not at risk for coverage right
yes you [ __ ] how that's not the point
dude like it's not the point it's not
isn't it like the smartest guy
no i thought he was
there's no way that they don't know that
they're missing the point
there's no way everybody understands
that it's about herd immunity
everybody understands that i don't
understand ignore my kid
so you won't do that no and why the [ __ ]
are these interviewees challenging him
does it matter that you're not at risk
that's something this interview if you
keep listening this interview does
challenge him and he gets very upset
oh really what do you do now do you do
you just go to work is that how you're
conducting yourself and your family yeah
yeah
this entire time spacex has been at work
this through this entire thing
we didn't skip a day you brag without
knowledge
security work we sent astronauts to the
space station and back
tesla has been apart from several weeks
where we're shut down by the state
and then overzealous alameda county
which is a travesty but apart from that
we've been making cars this entire time
and um it's been great how do you answer
your employees you say
i think you're putting me and my family
at risk
what do you say to them then stay home
that's it yeah do they get penalized for
that or just what's
it's what can they do if they feel that
they are
at risk i mean if they have a legitimate
reason to be at risk then
you know they should stay home all right
so when they decide what this is your
policy
when these workers are worried and do
you feel that they have a
i wouldn't just get back to that put
yourselves in their issues do you feel
they have
a good reason to be worried um and do
you feel a duty to pay them and make
sure they're okay
despite the fact that you don't agree
with how they feel about kovid versus
how you feel about it just move on
just move on no how about you answer the
[ __ ] question bro you're responsible
for a lot of people's help
how about you [ __ ] answer the
question [ __ ] you have a responsibility
for these people
danny just become like the richest
person yes
okay so he doesn't want to talk about if
he feels like he should be paying his
employees that feel like that dude
just move on you [ __ ] you play a little
bit more
cara i do not want to get into uh debate
about you i want to know situation
okay i want to finish up talking about
that in the
no we don't i don't want to end it i
just want to understand the standard
uh where you've got but i do i feel like
i understand where you are so
one of the things i should say we've
also spent quite a lot of time with the
hobbit epidemiology team
doing antibody studies tesla makes
the vaccine for machines for cure vac
gates said something about me not
knowing what what it's doing
it's like paid knucklehead we actually
make the vaccine machines for cure back
that company you're invested in cool
you're still putting your employees
at risk um but here he says
at the beginning he said i mean this is
a hot button issue where
rationality takes a back seat so
ironic in the grand scheme of things i
think this is
you know what we have is something with
a very low mortality rate
and high contagion and first of all the
mortality rate is like astonishingly
high for how contagious it is
i mean this whole talking point that it
has low mortality
the flu has more low mortality it has
like a point you know
zero one percent i don't know flu
mortality rate is like well below one
percent
this one has like
one to two percent mortality which is a
low number but that means
one out of every one hundred percent to
catch it dies
that's a [ __ ] lot versus the flu is
like one in ten thousand i mean that's a
staggering number of people
five hundred thousand people almost have
died elon i mean how the [ __ ] are you
gonna tell me that it has a low
mortality rate that sounds like a lot of
people dead
something that is of low risk to a young
person is of high risk to an older
person
and again they keep ignoring the fact
that there is a lot of people that have
long term lasting effects from covet
long lasting effects lung damage loss of
sense of smell
um it's he's very i honestly the only
thing i could say for elon
it makes more sense than joe rogan but
elon seems to just be protecting his
business interests right he's just
trying to ignore
the reality of it because he just wants
to keep doing business
so you know that seems pretty apparent
just watching him try to rationalize
this away
essentially the thing the right thing to
do would be to not have done a lockdown
for
the whole country but to have
i think anyone who's at risk should be
quarantined
until the storm passes all right but
this storm is coming again
you know by the way we tried that it's
not that
easy you all these people and you keep
going to parties with joe brogan
and um it's not gonna pass dude you
think they didn't try to lock down like
retirement homes
all these people are dying because
people need to [ __ ] interact with
other people the people that are highest
at risk
are people old of age and they have
caretakers and people that take care of
them
and it wipes them out like a [ __ ]
wildfire dude it's just
you're not this stupid to miss the
[ __ ] point
what about saving humanity but these are
humans that die in the process
everybody dies i know that wow he's so
[ __ ] enlightened
hey everybody dies classic that's this
is exactly what i want to run
and that's like the lex luthor defense
so disappointing everybody dies bro
that's that's like i'm 14 and this is
deep i mean what are you saying dude
you don't want to prevent death early
death
early death bro why do what's the point
of even trying to prevent
early infant mortality everybody dies
why should we care about babies though
that baby was just not healthy
yeah just it was a [ __ ] weak ass baby
you should go have a kid without any
life support and like
instruments to help your baby survive
elon because everybody dies
stupid ass such a [ __ ] idiot
god it's so upsetting oh yeah let's not
forget this gem
the elon musk back in march 19. based on
current trends
probably close to zero new cases by end
of
april i mean elon has consistently been
on the absolute wrong end of this cool
bro
is that a stat you got from joe well
people just believe him because he's
smart like
you know he's elon musk but yeah i'm
learning that elon is not
the [ __ ] cool dude that i thought he
was i really am disillusioned with him
yeah but have you seen like his doge
memes on twitter dude
it's so epic i can't believe people like
you think that's funny
he's so cringe bro to me he just strikes
me as like a mogul who really
is just focused on business over
everything he literally just said
everyone dies
when someone was confronting concern
about his employees
well i think it just a lot of people uh
fall into this trap of um
i mean i'm not i'm not about to say that
i'm smarter than elon musk
or that he's an idiot you know what i
mean i'm sure he has a very high iq but
being a talented engineer
and business person does not make you
smart
about everything else you know what i
mean and it it just
it's so obvious that the megalomania has
set in with him
that's it it's so simple joe rogan i
don't know what the [ __ ] to say about
your
okay he's just a dude it's more on brand
on joe rogan
just on brand i get that the
the question is what what on balance of
the greater good
and you feel lockdowns did not do that
no
this is a no-win situation it has it has
diminished my faith in humanity this
whole thing because diminished his faith
in humanity can you imagine the irony of
him saying that
the irrationality this is
pretty much where we started we've
looped around the video and then
this is to finish my defen diminish my
faith in humanity and fast forward one
minute can we stop talking about that
though
the well-being of my employees please
sorry dude
you [ __ ] it you and joe rogan diminish
my faith in humanity
it's so simple i mean
coming from the guy who during the year
of the pandemic became the richest guy
in the world
right now he was a good
a little more compassion to other people
he reached the point of like
money is like an abstract nothing it's
like
he has so much of it it's nothing yeah
everything is nothing it's like
it's so abstract at this point yeah that
you could do whatever you want you have
so much power to
just the pandemics
for example just treat your employees
nice like you have that power
i don't know
all right you know i think a way to
stick it in his face are you about to
defend them
no no way to stick it in his face just
show how you can be nice to your
employees and say [ __ ] elon
ethan i think you should give me your
tesla ah yeah he's got a point
yeah take it unfortunately i still have
to
if you want to take over the payments
you can have it yeah
yeah you want that elise no i'm just
playing you can have it
i swear to god i'm over tesla bro i
gotta say i'm kind of disappointed with
the tesla
i got the x and it's like it's rickety
oh you love it it feels rickety
it's a great car okay hila loves it
all right i can't stand these people
dude can't stand it
hey man amen
somebody gotta talk sense into joe rogan
though elon musk is a [ __ ] maniac
i wonder what this joel osteen has to
say about the vaccine oh mark of the
beast
for sure somebody's got to get to joe
rogan this is like a moon landing thing
like somebody's got to talk to this
[ __ ] guy
how can you look up to someone who
thought the moon landing was fake for
like 10 years i mean
how can you take anything they say
seriously
not to defend joe rogan but you know his
his
prominence as as a as a thought leader
if you will
is this is a recent development i mean
he he was i don't know he's been at that
for
years well he had a very popular podcast
but i mean he was just a stoner
having stoner talk in a basement for a
decade
hey joe rogan have you looked at the
ingredients in alpha brain i'm just
curious
here let me find the ingredients in
alpha burn it's a secret formula i think
oh okay yeah so let's take that every
day
he looks like he took captain america's
secret formula
that's why he doesn't need the vaccine
that's his nuclear brother it's not
funny
he's got the super soldiers here look i
didn't and with peace and love because i
know a lot of people love joe rogan but
i mean this kind of [ __ ] this kind of
there's been a a
a a definite shift in opinion against
rogan in the last year though if you go
to his subreddit they've completely
revolted
it's like the the the reddit joe rogan
subreddit is um really is it's like
pretty anti joey
look i know there's like a lot of let
blind left hate for rogan because
there's an affiliation with like
uh a lot of concert like really
conservative
people yes and no so it seems to bridge
the gap
though from what i've seen because um
it's it's more about stuff like this
like the coveted stuff
i i i checked out the comments on um on
this particular clip
oh for real yeah there was a lot of like
jesus christ he's really
really [ __ ] also a lot of it has to
do with everybody really hates
his whole spotify thing um because i
guess the whole role out of it has been
kind of a disaster so um
there's there's a lot of ill will for
him right now with his fan base
look i got no problem with joe and
talking with right-wing people i
i think conversations are good and stuff
my problem is with the conspiracy
theories and this
absolute [ __ ] ignorant mis like
missing the point
so hard that i just can't believe it and
it's just so harmful
so dangerous you know i just it's
bro
i just can't do it here let's pretend
it's fear factor joe
and you have to get a shot a vaccine
shot to
overcome your fears and turn into some
kind of alpha thing about overcoming
your feelings you can win
fifty thousand dollars come on just do
it
do it don't be a [ __ ] that'll get him
don't be a [ __ ] dude overcome your
fears you could do it
we got a psychiatrist we'll come
anyway that's what i'm pissed off
do we have uh any light goofs to round
the show out with no
i want this bitterness to stay in
people's mouth
because it is bitter
hey i want to [ __ ] see my parents i
want to go do [ __ ] with theodore who's
locked in the house for two years
i want to go do [ __ ] we all want to go
do [ __ ] as long as you dip shits are not
getting the fact that you've seen
any friends since this whole thing
started so [ __ ] over it
no one has any life anymore
everyone's gonna start getting depressed
it's just
not them they're out no wonder they
don't give a [ __ ] because they're
already living their life like it
doesn't exist
well yeah right and they are partying as
they don't even feel bad posting about
it on instagram
what are we going to do what are we
going to do i i just hope kenneth
copeland is praying hard enough to make
this thing
go away
that's crazy all right well that was fun
we've covered a lot of ground i'm
curious to see how the comments react to
the david dobrik discussion
are you worried ab i i mean i know it's
coming so
at least i'm not gonna be blindsided but
it's going to be arrest
interesting i feel like i don't do a
good job explaining myself i mean you
got through to us a little bit at the
end there
yeah i'm not saying david's innocent or
anything like i'm just saying that
trisha is not going to she will she will
have no yeah
well as of now she still follows me on
tick tock let's see how long it takes
interesting just reminded her i don't
think she'll unfollow you she's just
gonna [ __ ]
she's just gonna [ __ ] on you if like on
on tick tock or something she'll like
clip you and talk [ __ ]
should be crazy i'm gonna wrap it up
we'll be here on friday live you know
what it is h3
live it is here all day all day you know
what it is
got a little heated this episode but
sometimes you gotta get heated i'm just
[ __ ] not okay with this
you know we all gotta
we all gotta do our part man it's hard
that's the part we all gotta sacrifice
for the greater good all right
come on man
come on man bye bye
bye bye bye bye